[Music]
good morning are you all asleep out
there good morning good good good
welcome back to Saturday classes now
those of you who are my age and older
know about Saturday classes you young
folks you missed a great opportunity
instead of sleeping in on Saturday
morning you would get up he would go to
the lab and you would do an experiment
which undoubtedly was going to fail now
it may have been failing because you
were dead asleep
didn't do it right and it may have been
failing because the physics department
intended it to to teach you a lesson
about physics on the other hand we're
not going to have any experiments this
morning
welcome it's my pleasure to welcome you
to what believe it or not is my last
welcome for a technology day I've done
this for 23 years now and I I've
actually held a job for almost half of
its historical history and I'm finally
going to go half time on July 1st so
welcome back to tech as you know those
of you who are my age and have a little
gray in your hair this police keeps
changing and for the most part for the
better it's my pleasure this morning to
do one thing and that's introduce our
president Chuck vest
thank you very much bill this being MIT
I carry some instrumentation around it
measures the relative humidity and it
works this way when I make it from gray
house the president's home to Kresge in
five minutes flat and stand up to speak
it's a question of how quickly my
glasses fall go so just watch them and
you'll tell before we begin this morning
I just really want to be sure that
everybody heard what Bill Hecht just
said we've been remarkably fortunate as
an institution to have an individual who
has been so dedicated and so effective
to maintaining the alumni family of MIT
strong and vigorous and moving forward
it's been a terrific run it of course as
bill said he's held the job for the
majority of its existence he's held it
for all of my existence as a member of
the community and bill I just want to
personally thank you and thank you on
behalf of those thousands of men and
women out there who owe so much to you
thank you
but being MIT we have a new
vice-president and one who will be
equally extraordinary and wonderful in
her tenure Beth Garvin who's also with
us this morning Beth welcome well I know
she's here somewhere because I saw her a
few moments ago but let's let's get down
to work it's really a great time to
welcome all of you back to your campus
because this has been an absolutely
terrific year in terms of accomplishment
and momentum on the part of our faculty
and their students as well as our staff
and our alumni I think you've had a look
around at parts of the campus and you
can see steel and brick and metal and
some other materials you probably are
wondering what they are rising here and
there these are the physical or outward
symbols of an institution that is both
bold and very confident in its future
and I think we have good reason for both
that boldness and certainly for that
confidence in our future the campus is
continuing its transformation in the
area of residential and community life
this year alone we opened Simmons Hall
the magnificent new undergraduate
dormitory just to the north of the
playing fields we opened a much larger
residence hall for graduate students a
little bit further to the north at the
intersection of Sydney and Pacific
Streets and we opened the Magnificent
zessica sports and fitness center which
I hope all of you have an opportunity to
have a look at while you are here I must
say I've never anywhere seen or heard of
a building that has had a more
instantaneous transformational effect on
a campus community as
has zessica Center the Z Center as it is
known in the vernacular with its
magnificent Olympic pool and workout
rooms and squash courts and so forth and
it's just busy and humming 24 hours a
day and mixing together our staff and
our students and our faculty in really
an extraordinary way and of course
contributing to the Wellness of our
community in the agenda for research and
teaching we are in the final stages of
what has been a horrendous but very
important project to renovate the
chemistry building from top to bottom to
really bring it up to modern standards
of safety and so forth to allow us to
continue the movement of chemistry into
so many new areas of nanoscale science
and biologically based chemistry and so
forth and to do so in a way that is safe
that minimizes the amounts of chemicals
that need to be used and so forth it's
just wonderful about 2/3 of it is
finished and occupied we're doing the
last phase even as we speak this morning
and I hope you all have seen the rain
Maria Stata Center for computational
information and intelligence sciences
that's rising at the site of the famous
building 20 and really in so many ways
symbolizes the advance of MIT into a new
century it has two major elements the
Alex Dreyfus building and the Bill Gates
building and I just hope you do have a
look at Frank Gehry's magnificent
structure which is about at the point
you can begin to really sense what it's
going to be like as a building and I'm
sure this time next year we will be
holding some portion of these events
within it last week we had the
groundbreaking over the last two weeks
for the new brain and cognitive science
complex that will consist of three
integrated buildings the McGovern
Institute for brain research the pick
our Center for
learning in memory and the facilities of
the department of brain and cognitive
science itself very may a symbol of a
very major intellectual advance for the
campus terms of quality of life were
slowly but surely working away at all
the important infrastructure the
terribly important things that you don't
see life safety systems in the residence
halls and so forth
and also making some advances toward
improving our streetscapes you will see
within the next year that at least the
eastern part of Vassar Street that is to
the east of Mass Ave is going to become
the kind of thoroughfare that this
campus really and its people really
deserve with nice paving and trees and
bicycle paths and a little less parking
and so forth going to be a great great
improvement in teaching and research we
continue to have the best there is
we celebrated two remarkable
anniversaries this year back in the fall
we celebrated the fiftieth year of the
Sloan School of Management in a
wonderful MIT combination of
intellectual events and celebration and
just over the land just last week we had
an extraordinary celebration of the
100th year of electrical engineering
here at MIT with again a magnificent set
of lectures as well as celebrity events
and I made the statement at the opening
of that event that I'm going to repeat
here I do not believe there has ever
existed an academic department in any
institution in the world that has had as
much influence on education and also on
practice in its field as has mi t--'s
Department of Electrical Engineering and
computer science at that
at that time it was announced that the
laboratory for computer science and the
artificial intelligence laboratory have
merged to form a new entity and also
during the intervening week we opened
the new Institute for soldier
nanotechnology which is a remarkable 50
million dollar undertaking of our
faculty and students on behalf of the US
Army which will also form an incredible
platform for the young faculty from many
different departments who put this
program together to explore the new
world of nanoscale science and nanoscale
engineering computational and systems
biology again a cross-disciplinary group
put together by an extraordinary group
of young faculty here at MIT is
something I think you will be reading
about over the coming decade they're
just remarkable group of people with
wonderful ideas about how to blend the
way engineers think with the way
biologists and medical doctors must
think as we enter this new century we've
continued innovation and teaching and
level and learning at all levels our
opencourseware program will really ramp
up this fall with about 500 subjects on
it and our pilot sites have had just
remarkable responses from across the
country and especially all around the
world but the heart of all of this is
our remarkable faculty and their
students this fall the class of 2007
will arrive and I have to tell you every
year these young men and women get
better and better it's going to be a
truly remarkable group this year MIT
faculty were recognized by receiving the
highest awards in virtually each of our
core areas that began with the Nobel
Prize for medicine physiology that went
to bob horvitz of our biology department
our Cancer Center and also the McGovern
Institute for brain research
for his pioneering work some years back
in understanding programmed cell death
which has great importance of course to
the field of cancer research and as he
is beginning to learn to the field of
neuroscience as well the National Medal
of Science went to Ann Graybiel of our
brain and cognitive science department
and I have to tell you I was fortunate
to be in the White House for that event
and it felt really good to see eight men
and one women one woman on the stage and
she was the one from MIT we were very
proud of and the Draper prize the Draper
prize this year the highest award an
engineer can win in the United States
went to our own Bob Langer for his
incredible work in biotechnology and by
the way bob was the cover boy of the
Boston Globe Sunday magazine last week
with a big banner headline that said the
smartest man in Boston how would you
like to live up to that that's quite an
accomplishment the Turing award the
Turing award the highest computer
science award given in the world really
went to Ron Rivest who shared it with
two former MIT people for their seminal
work on public key encryption some years
back but even more important to me is
what's happening with our very young
faculty we had Daniel Mellon athan in
economics won one of the so-called
MacArthur Genius Awards this year and
Angela aiment a young professor in our
biology department won what in many ways
to me is the most impressive award in
this entire list which is the Waterman
award that the National Science Board
gives every year to one one scientist or
engineer in any field for research
accomplishments under the age of 35 and
so the future I can tell you as at least
as bright as the present and as our past
and finally this last week was announced
that christen for
Erbs a young applied economist here at
MIT in the Sloan School has been
nominated to serve on President Bush's
Council of Economic Advisers so I'm
through bragging for a little while mr.
lash and I think it's time to get on
with seeing the substance behind the
bragging we have a wonderful morning put
together for you to sample a bit of the
intellectual potpourri that is MIT and
to start that I would like to introduce
to you you're president of the Alumni
Association my friend and colleague Jim
lash Jim I am NOT the substance just to
be clear about that you have of course
your booklet and the booklet outlines
the program for today my job is to try
to keep it moving along I will be
introducing the speakers and after I've
introduced each speaker and they've
given their talk there will be a brief
question and answer period you should
have received when you came in three by
five cards on which you may write your
questions we're not going to be picking
those cards up we want you to read the
question from the card why would we do
that well it's because the speeches are
to be given on the stage not out there
and you're not to come on the stage so
we want you to to try to keep it brief
because we only have a short period of
time the program this morning consists
of five individuals actually today
consists of five individuals one from
each of our schools the first is dr.
Lawrence Vale head of the department of
urban studies and planning and he will
be speaking with us today on the subject
of housing the lowest income Americans
the past present and future of public
housing you have his biography in your
material but I just wanted to give you a
sense of how committed he is to this
subject I have a long list of books and
articles he has written on this subject
and they have titles like urban design
for urban development the future of
planned poverty redeveloping America's
most to distress
public housing projects from the
Puritans to the projects the ideological
origins of American public housing
public housing and the American dream
residence views of buying into the
projects without further ado dr. Vale at
this time of reunions when alumni and
alumni come back on their alma mater z--
I realize I'm something of a 20th
century relic I finished a graduate
program here at MIT 15 years ago and
forgot to leave and have never applied
for any other job than the one I
currently hold a very strange notion
although faculty members even here at
MIT sometimes like to complain about
salaries my title today housing the
lowest income Americans is not meant to
be particularly autobiographical rather
I wanted to spend a few moments with you
today talking about public housing which
aside from prisons I think is probably
the country's most vilified and signify
stigmatized domestic environment if you
ask people these days where it is that
they think the lowest America lowest
income Americans live they they probably
don't give you an answer like slums or
ghettos anymore they probably would say
public housing and there are 1.3 million
households about 4 or 5 million
Americans living in public housing today
and the census showed that during the
1990s 9 out of the 10 most distressed
economically most distressed
neighborhoods in the country were in
fact public housing projects something
that we're largely the creation of
direct federal policy a strange notion
the worst examples of public housing
certainly deserve their their dismal
reputation although most public housing
surely in smaller communities is
functioning quite well we sometimes
forget that their 3,500 public housing
authorities across the country and we
usually hear the the most negative
things only about the few in some of the
largest cities that have gone so far
astray but they failed so dramatically
that it's understandable that that that
happens
um so Mike my my interest in this is to
try and put some perspective on it going
both backwards and forwards and and I
really have been struggling for the last
several years with too two questions in
particular how and why did public
housing in this country fall into such
ill repute and second what can be done
to fix this the both of them turn out to
be fairly complicated questions let me
begin by asking you to judge a couple of
books by their covers
there they're up there probably not the
best thing to do
neither of these books is is likely to
become a best-seller but at least
displayed this way there I can claim
that they're the largest sellers and
I'll be sure to tell this to Harvard
University Press the the book on the
left I'm reminded by the title of today
being Fast Times at MIT you'll see
whether I qualify the book on the Left
started as research on my undergraduate
thesis in 1980 and was published as a
book a mere 20 years later and the book
on the right fared only slightly better
I began work on it during my first
semester as a master's student and
completed it this fall during my first
semester as a department head so I'm not
a particularly speedy researcher but
these are problems these are really not
problems that emerged quickly or that
will be solved quickly the title of the
the book on the left the first book that
from the Puritans to the projects is
meant to suggest that the problem of
public housing is embedded in about 350
years of past cultural practices
specifically notions about work ethics
and a sense that the poverty is usually
caused
by some sort of individual moral failing
and in a belief that government the town
has an obligation to help those who are
worse off the people that I call in the
subtitle public neighbors that the
government would step in the town if
those people couldn't be supported by
their family or by private charities
here in Boston that's the way things
work three hundred and fifty years ago
in that view of the world the single
family pub the single family home was
the thing that really remained supreme
even even hundreds of years ago as it
does now and multi-family housing going
back historically was something that was
associated with institutions the the
second project which culminated in the
the book reclaiming public housing is
attempting to tell the story of public
housing primarily from the viewpoint of
its tenants in other words the first
project is a long story about how
various institutions managed poverty in
cities a tale of where people in
positions of power chose to put the
poorest citizens and where where poor
people tended to need together as well
whereas the second book is a more of a
bottom-up kind of story
it's about the rise of public housing a
rise that that many of the people in
this room can remember was during a
period of optimism about what the
government could do for low-income
people in housing but it's also about
the collapse of public housing and most
importantly it's about three ambitious
attempts to try and revitalize
particular housing developments
reclaiming them not just as buildings
but as safe and secure communities for
continued occupancy by very low income
households the advantage of taking so
long to to write these books is that I
was able to watch and observe the
transformation of these places over a
period of more than 15 years I asked you
to judge these books by their their
covers but doing so also means looking
closely at what is
they're even those of you who are closed
up probably can can recognize that
people are not shown in in either of
these covers the key ethical challenge
for my work really is to make sure that
I always remember that I'm not writing
about buildings or at least not just
about buildings but about the people who
design and manage and transform and live
in these buildings more than 300
interviews were conducted with such
people so my challenge has been to try
and contribute to a scholarship in
history and urban planning and social
science but also to make sure that my
books were going to do so in a way that
paid full respect to the people that I
was writing about I call this the doing
projects in the projects challenge
there's a glaring disparity here that
that I want to be upfront about with you
a researcher from the second-richest
institution in Cambridge and I well
maybe that's not right maybe Harvard is
in Boston now but anyway coming from a
place of wealth and privilege privilege
I'm spending years studying some of the
the poorest people in Boston so what do
these people gain from my study right
how can I avoid the sort of intrusive
exploitation that has characterized past
generations of social science research
in other words what's in this for them I
don't have a time now for a full
discussion of that question but I want
to emphasize that I began the inquiry
with the public housing tenants
themselves through slowly nurtured
relationships with the the leadership
and others at the the tenant
organizations in the housing
developments that I was attempting to
analyze the tenants themselves helped
shape the kinds of questions that that
were asked of their fellow tenants and
encouraged me to to find ways to raise
issues that were going to be important
to them as well as to me
that was really the prerequisite for
mutual trust and it constituted the only
hope that I had that the kind of
interviews that we're going to be done
with these people
who otherwise had no particular reason
to trust me or my institution that they
were going to be honest and in open and
candid the most critical thing was to a
decision to actually hire public housing
residents themselves to do much of the
interviewing and to train them and to
try and provide them with a skill to
come out of this rather than the white
male professor coming across the river
to do his project in the projects I was
hoping that the tenants would be able to
see this as something more of a joint
venture and I wanted them to see that
the most of the money that went to this
research was going to them rather than
to the MIT student Ras that they
perceived as rich and privileged people
even though those same students regarded
themselves as low-income individuals on
this side of the river so what I was
doing was valuing their time at the rate
of $10 an hour and implicitly valuing
their viewpoints by by doing that so the
result was 267 hour-long taped
interviews in in four languages they
were conducted in four languages that
were really intended to to get at a much
broader range of opinion and viewpoint
not just the loud activist tenant tenant
spokesperson but to try and get at what
people who hadn't been asked about
anything had to say about life in public
housing and what could happen it had a
lot of downsides certainly mostly due to
the logistical complexity of that and to
the highly variable interviewing skills
of the people we hired and I'm sure that
it never really was fully viewed as the
joint venture that I intended but I
still think it it marks a small attempt
to counter some of the stereotypes that
still are prevalent about people living
in public housing and the worlds they
inhabit so let me just now with with the
aid of some illustrations spend a few
minutes illustrating three aspects of
American public housing struggle first
is this struggle to build public housing
in a country that venerates home
ownership and
individual initiative second is the
struggle to maintain the high idealism
that initially characterized public
housing construction and third is the
struggle to reclaim public housing
projects for continued occupancy by
low-income people so if you look at the
what I what I tend to call the
prehistory of public housing arguing
that it goes back 350 years and not just
to the New Deal like most people think
of it there is a long term tension
between two trends one a sense that if
government and the state are involved in
any kind of housing provision for
low-income people that it ought to be a
reward for the best kind of people it
ought to be recognizing your your
contributions to the town your service
to country through veterans programs
through land grants and things like that
or alternatively it it ought to be
acknowledging that the federal
government or the state government or
some form of government has a kind of
public obligation to the least advantage
that it's a kind of way of coping with
poverty a coping mechanism so I always
try to think of public housing in the
context of its antithesis they the
private home some of you may not be able
to read all of this and I don't have the
the little laser printer laser pointer
with me to to show this but what it says
here is his castle home owning breeds
real men and then in the fine print at
the bottom it says it's what puts the
man back in manhood this is an
illustration from the 1922 booklet by
the national association of real estate
boards called own your own home here
does brown own his own no he rents
haven't you seen him scratch matches on
the wallpaper there is this inferior
moral being out here known as the renter
that is being vilified and stigmatized
by by this alternative so the kinds of
images of homeownership in the years
immediately preceding public housing the
homeowner as the most efficient workman
and the most successful in business and
the professions at the upper left a home
as the best-known incentive to
persistent an organized effort or down
below the the woman in her garden where
it says what woman does not yearn for
her own garden and flowers the work of
caring for them and the sunshine helped
to keep her young or the woman in the up
and if the garden weren't enough the
modern kitchen of the owned home the
little caption says no drudgery here so
so this is what you gain or finally for
for children it what it says here is
every child has the right to a home of
its own the child raised in a rented
house or apartment is cheated
it makes childhood happier so this is
the sort of thing that's going on and we
know it well historically going back to
the 19th century the Homestead Act there
there's one from Oklahoma on the left
and then here in Massachusetts there was
an organization in the 19-teens called
the Homestead Commission that was
building houses for worthy upwardly
mobile workers in Lowell Massachusetts
one of the earliest forms so you have
this kind of reward trend a tradition
for on the one hand trying to to say
that they the way that government
belongs in housing is to reward the
people who are the most deserving who
are going to work the land or who have
served as veterans or who have done one
thing or another to to gain from that
and alternatively there's this other
long tradition about housing and
government involvement as a kind of
coping mechanism this is a the almshouse
in Boston on Leverett Street right about
where Mass General is now are part of it
that was built in 1800 to replace the
earlier alms house on Boston Common it
was designed by Charles Bulfinch the
same two
as the the new Statehouse and when they
built the new Statehouse I didn't want
the old zoms house across the street
from it and so it moved over but but got
very prominent kind of thing so people
that really couldn't afford to maintain
themselves on the town were there and
then gradually went even even further
the now that I have my pointer that's
the Boston Peninsula that was there in
the 19th century and what initially
happened was that Leverett house 1 was
about as far as you could get to that
point and then that wasn't far enough or
big enough and so they moved it all the
way out to Deer Island which at that
point was still an island and built this
thing by 1850 as a almshouse and house
of industry meaning able-bodied people
should be put to work it was actually
almost a form of incarceration with
visits only possible once every three
months and they and it being an island
they didn't allow for anybody to elope
with the phrase meaning escape from from
it at the time so you see you had this
kind of sense of put people put poor
people in an institution of course most
people were left in tenements on the
mainland and this book that came out in
1893 as Boston's equivalent of the
famous Jacob Riis book how the other
half lives
is called civilizations Inferno studies
in the social cellar and what it was was
a study of what happened while the
people were dancing on the streets of in
the in the town houses of Beacon Hill or
the Back Bay and the levels of poverty
that existed the worthy people looking
for work over here the widows and
orphans who were poor through no fault
of their own and then the so called
social seller the the world of vice and
illicit behavior and all of the sorts of
things and the attempt was to figure out
which of these people you should care
about do you care about these people and
these people but not those people how do
you distinguish what happens in the
inferno of civilization but it's not
until the 20th century that people
started to to worry about this in any
any great detail this is a map of Boston
and
in Cambridge showing what they called to
be sections in which are blighted areas
that may be considered for rehousing
projects that was the phrase so we are
there's Main Street and we're Memorial
Drive would be running there so we're
just sort of in here there's my self and
and if you know Cambridge you know that
they're two very large public housing
developments right here at that Main
Street intersection over there that did
get built so this is the idea but the
question was well what was meant by re
rehousing projects the the authority
came to power this is the way the Boston
Housing Authority preferred to
self-reference themselves so these five
guys and their and their descendants
were in charge
self-appointed of picking who was going
to go into public housing Boston shown
here at the top had two big bursts one
pre-war and one post-war where all of
the housing was built this is the
national picture which also has the
pre-war spike a post-war spike but had
more activity in the 50s and 60s
Boston stopped building the large public
housing projects for families in 1954
ahead of most other cities but was but
did a lot of it very very soon
and what was happening as at least in
the older days is that there were
neighborhoods being taken like this one
with hundreds of individual structures
including homes that people owned in
businesses that were owned that were
simply being torn down a line is drawn
around it and it's it's rebuilt this is
the Mission Hill district in in Roxbury
one of the first one in 1940 that was
was taken and this question of rehousing
project turned out that it was about
building new housing over here but not
really about rehousing those people into
this place what happened when I look
back at it and looked at the population
records I found that between 50 and 70
or 50 and 80 percent of the people in
these various neighborhoods that were
being torn down expressed an interest in
moving to public housing but when it
when they actually built it only between
2 and 12 percent actually got in because
these people had the wrong family size
they they might have been single
individuals or they might have had an
extended family they might not have had
a US citizen at the head of the
household they might have been the wrong
race for a project that was going to be
only for one race or the other and it
was a black/white issue in those in
those days in Boston they might have not
had a stable enough job because public
housing was a reward in those days it
wasn't a coping mechanism it was a
reward for the people who who really had
demonstrated good citizenship and good
housekeeping and were likely to make
maximum advantage and move on as quickly
as possible so someone else could take
their place that's the kind of thing
that was happening the the idea was as
the cartoon here says it says the man's
holding the bag here of the slum
clearance tool and it says diseased
dispirited 'no still in Quincy we hope
you'll be gone with the slums the idea
was you you tear down the slums and you
eliminate the problems but what was lost
in the equations was that in fact you
were just inviting a very different
group of people to return public housing
in 1940 in Boston was more selective
than MIT there were 10,000 applications
for a thousand places in a public
housing development when it opened I
think MIT selectivity has improved since
then but but in any case it was really
this kind of sense of moral uplift you
can't read all the details here but it
says out of the shadows into the Sun the
nation of the notion of back alleys here
and then the kind of openness of public
housing and the the the sentence which
is is too good not to to read to you
says after after the war there were
eight shining developments rising fresh
to the Sun where once in dreary dirt
filled dilapidation slum dwellings had
shambled in contaminating hopelessness
against a gray and somber sky in this
day public housing was intended to even
fix the weather of Boston
you know it it really was was was there
so this was a period of optimism and
openness an opportunity when people took
pictures of public housing projects they
emphasize things like flag poles and the
Bunker Hill Monument at the Charlestown
development or here in Mission Hill the
mission church almost looks like the
town Church on the common and the the
the the references were all to New
England villages people wanted it here
in Boston every one of those circles is
a the site of a post-war housing
development where every one of the city
councilor said well what about Ward 24
we didn't get ours yet there there were
seventeen of these built after after the
war to complement the eight that were
done before now this was this was a
desired thing but note also that the
gray areas were the only areas where
there was a majority non-white
population in Boston
in other words 23 of these these
developments are 22 of them were built
in white neighborhoods and intended for
white occupancy and so some of the the
real challenges for housing has been
what do you do as the neighborhoods
change and as the population of the town
changes when you have done a housing
stock like that it's been a real
question
but the idea really was that these these
were slum neighborhoods like that map I
showed here this is a this map is a
close-up of that area of South Boston
and the idea was this was a substandard
area known as census tract m3 and the
idea was it it just cost too much to the
city there were all of these various
kinds of expenses ranging from street
cleaning to to health costs and that
this was a lost net revenue loss and so
the idea was to tear it down and you put
something else there and you get other
other people so you got these dramatic
before-and-after kind of pictures that's
the same neighborhood they they simply
drew a little red line that you may be
able to barely see tore down hundreds of
places left the Lithuanian church that
was in here but destroyed the entire
parish that was around it and then
rebuilt
rebuilt public housing for a thousand
nine hundred and seventy two units of
housing and handed it over to Irish
American occupancy the Lithuanian and
Polish communities of South Boston have
never forgiven this so the struggle
though has been what do you do when when
this stuff starts to decline and I don't
have time to give you the whole the
whole picture which is which is fairly
well known but increasingly you had
Meteor people applying all of those
white upwardly mobile veterans were
given all sorts of other opportunities
through various federal initiatives and
the way the housing markets were working
under the FHA at the time and
increasingly didn't need or want to
apply for public housing once the 1950s
and 60s started you had people that had
had much less stable employment choosing
to apply the financial system of public
housing was premise taun the rents
covering the occupancy the the operating
expenses and that was increasingly
impossible when you had people bringing
in lower incomes the management failures
and the maintenance failures are legion
and the design inadequacy of these
places that had hundreds and hundreds of
children thousands in some cases and
clustered on stairwells and and reliant
on unreliable elevators that sort of
thing so by the end of the 1970s in
Boston and elsewhere public housing had
declined dramatically this is the same
project in South Boston that I showed
just a moment ago of the aerial where
where nobody really knew what was public
what was private what was Street what
was asphalt for what was courtyard
this I think may have been the last tree
and they're not any tall beavers in
South Boston in case your case you're
wondering but it it's the kind of thing
that was happening and when I first
started visiting they actually had to
annotate the the public street sign to
say private way dangerous passing a very
sad commentary so the question is well
what do you do about that
the answer in st. Louis in famously in
the 1970s was to take the infamous
pruitt-igoe project and blow it up the
problem having done that as the aerial
photo of st. Louis taken at least 15
years later shows is that there wasn't
anything in there to replace it this is
the open field that is on the site of
that that I took about two or three
years ago when I went to visit it
there's even been a proposal for a golf
course but it it's a very you know it's
a very short-sighted answer you know it
this is the answer this is give up but I
don't think that's the way to do it the
current thinking is under the federal
hope six program it says here these are
some HUD brochures of it says hope six
building communities transforming lives
promise fulfilled the transformations of
American public housing these are all
before after before after the the kind
of dramatic transformation and this one
says principles for inner-city
neighborhood design the idea being that
you tear it all down and you rebuild it
as mixed income communities and start
all over and try and attract a different
set of people here's a kind of example
again in st. Louis the court of public
housing and the housing that's being
replaced it the catch in all of this is
that it's asking a different kind of
person to benefit this is now public
housing for those people the kind of
multiracial briefcase set and and it's
not serving the people that public
housing had become intended to serve if
you if you actually look at the the
figures it it's it's very disturbing
about how few very low income people are
now going into the redeveloped housing
it's it's being torn down and then
replaced with a different kind of tenant
just like like what happened in the
1930s and 40s during the slum clearance
when the new housing was not intended
for those people
so the alternative that that I've been
proposing is what I call reclaiming
public housing which means not just
reclaiming the buildings but but
reclaiming the occupancy for very
low-income people and so what I did was
look at at places and I'm just telling
you about the most successful of them
since time is short the the Commonwealth
Development in in Boston which I think
is probably the most successful
turnaround of a severely distressed
public housing development anywhere in
the country not just here when it when
it opened it was for veterans housing
650 units here and a lot of children and
a lot of milk trucks
this is 1951 and it had mid-rise
buildings and elevators and all of these
things that are not supposed to work in
public housing it worked pretty well for
a while it opened as an integrated
they'll barely integrated development in
in the early 50s which was considered
extremely progressive at the at the time
and remained a hollow rural place to
live into the early 1970s these fellows
Stephen Brown and John Murphy were best
friends in the early 1970s and and a lot
of the the climate managed to miss the
the real tensions over busing that tore
apart so much of the other city but by
the end of the 1970s for all of these
reasons that I mentioned Commonwealth
declined dramatically by 1980 it was 52%
vacant only 14% of the households had
employment full-time employment 94% of
the households were headed by a single
female only 11 percent of the people
when when interviewed said they felt
very safe the judge who put the Boston
Housing Authority in receivership in
1980 said that the development was
regarded by neighbors with fear and
loathing were his words when people
moved out as they did often without
notice no one was able to secure the
apartments they were vandalized and then
proved
unrented ball so you ended up things
like with things like this and you ended
up with the kind of picture that that
characterized that the top of this which
is just at the beginning of the efforts
to reconstruct it but people didn't give
up nor did they give it over to
wealthier people what happened was the
transformation from this plan to this
which may look very similar except for
the color to you but note a couple of
things instead of that building here is
a daycare center instead of that
building here is a management center and
a community center and instead of these
buildings separate they're connected
over here in a special complex of
housing to serve needs of the elderly
and another road was put through here so
it didn't just seem like a single loop
through it the the tenant leadership was
crucial this man Bart McDonough was the
tenant leader at the time at the opening
of the childcare center here and they
did a fabulous job of organizing
themselves and working with with people
to assert their needs especially their
right to return to the redeveloped place
the the design it's a little hard to to
read the one on the on the left but what
they did was they turn Huayra turned
three-story buildings that had had
apartments on each floor into townhouse
type things so that when somebody was on
a stoop they could actually talk to
somebody on the street and it really
transformed the design into something
much closer to a normal streetscape and
they landscaped it beautifully as much
as 10 feet of fill was put in here and
it became a place where people had a
sense of what was private and what was
semi-private and where the public realm
was and and lastly they turned it over
to a very first-rate private management
team that that occupied part of this
building along with the tenant tenant
offices and it got to a point where a
place that had been considered so
dangerous that nobody would go near it
in the late 1970s by the mid-1980s they
had to erect resident parking only signs
because there were people from the
suburbs that we're coming and parking on
site at Commonwealth Development and
then getting on the Green Line to
commute the rest of their way to their
jobs it's just a remarkable kind of
transformation of a neighborhood and of
an attitude done by this this tremendous
kind of thing it's ultimately I think a
function of community this is a sign I
saw in the community center that some of
the kids had put together welcome to our
community room rules no cussing fighting
jumping on tables groping stealing ball
playing drinking smoking throwing
spitting teasing or running warning one
warning then you must leave on on number
two this was a this was an effort to
restore community in a place that that
was done so without a loss to a
commitment to extremely low-income
people
the redevelopment succeeded in fostering
safety and reliability and quality
management and attractive conditions
without replacing the population with a
less needy group I wish it were the
national model but it isn't
instead a a recent study of the five
billion dollar federal program known as
Hope six some of you who saw the globe
yesterday it was a big discussion of it
on page three the the program that's
known as hope 6h ope six found that only
11 percent of those who had lived in the
neighborhoods that were in severely
distressed public housing that were
being replaced by the hope six program
actually got back in to the redeveloped
housing or the or slated to do so in
other words it's that same kind of 10%
people get back that we noticed in the
30s and 40s so I don't make any friends
at HUD when I suggest that the Hope
acronym really ought to stand for house
are poor people elsewhere let me briefly
conclude then by returning to this
question of ethics I began with a few
words about methodology and about the
need to address the power relations that
are inherent in studying our fellow
human beings but
clearly the ethical challenge in this
kind of work is really a double one it's
not just a matter of method but also of
content in terms of content we really
have to remember that the entire field
of housing is infused with moral
judgments each of us consciously or not
is is making moral judgments about a
person based on where he or she lives
and to study public housing is about
making society accessible societal
judgments about the the place of poor
people in cities so really at base I'm
interested in the history of public
housing not just because it tells us so
much about who we were and who we are
but because it helps us explain and
inform action in the present that
sentence alone is probably enough to
keep me from ever having a joint
appointment in a history department but
but it's really an essential perspective
to have for someone interested in urban
planning my field takes entails taking
action in the world building theory out
of a close observation of practice ours
is really a never ending kind of search
to make sense out of the messiest parts
of the world and I thank you for letting
me share a part of my search with you
this morning
let's say you can stay right there
alright we now come to the participation
part of the program we're going to start
here and sort of work our way across
with questions investment in his own
residence there won't be the accompany
responsibility for upkeep is there any
validity to that I think there there is
I I showed one of my graduate students
yesterday a slide about rent but Brown
and his match scratching as a renter and
she says well I was a homeowner in New
Haven and now I'm a renter in Boston and
I don't want to do anything for this
landlord that's got my place I mean
that's an anecdote but the interesting
thing from my work and I didn't show the
images today is looking at what people
were doing in these redeveloped places
with the area immediately outside of
their apartments it used to be that
public housing was often considered
there was a real split between the
beautiful upkeep of the interior of the
apartment and then disaster the moment
you stepped out the door into the
hallways and all of that but in these
more successfully redeveloped places
what you find is that people are taking
control over some of the the semi-public
space immediately outside the area
whether it's an interior the building or
outside and and people are doing gardens
and vegetable vegetable gardens and
flowers and that when when people have a
sense of security about their
environment I find that they're taking
some personal investment in it so I'm
sure that what you say is absolutely
true but but when you restore some
stability and security and good
management I think that people respect
that and respond accordingly here if
there are low-income requirements for
occupying housing how can this not then
have a negative effect on a family's
ambition to advance economically well
one of the there have been a number of
measures taken recently on that it used
to be the the the the problem was that
people advanced so quickly that they
were kicked out of public housing in the
in the early days because it didn't they
would go over income now because there's
some interest in maintaining some of
them the more stable earning families
there are ceiling rents so that after a
certain point you don't have to pay a
portion of your the 30% of your rent to
remain and that that will encourage some
people to remain and diversify the
community by by incomes so it is it is
certainly a problem and I think the the
the goal for any good community ought to
be that there are some people who who
become lifelong residents and other
people who who last there only a short
while and then move onward and upward to
something else and the the hope is that
people will will not have to be sending
the next generation through public
housing and the interesting thing about
Common Wealth where where where the
unemployment rate is still very high is
that they have a much higher percentage
of the younger people going on to
college than other public housing in
Boston and and it seems to me that by
stabilizing the environment there are
there are new opportunities for the next
generation that might not otherwise have
happened the question in this section of
the three that that I wrote about we're
all all in Boston the Austin Brighton
area where Commonwealth is South Boston
and Dorchester and particular
developments within them the other two
being West Broadway are known as D
Street in South Boston and Franklin
field along Blue Hill Avenue in
Dorchester and I found that there was
almost as much diversity within a single
city as there would be if I had done a
more nationally comparative kind of
study I think in the next section
I think that's a great question
oh sorry what what how much success does
success depend on a single charismatic
individual I don't think that there was
a single charismatic individual at at
the Commonwealth success what there was
was a a nurturing of ability for tenants
to speak to speak outward about what was
really bothering them and people who
were initially not terribly effective in
public settings gained that kind of
confidence but it was a process that was
really cast with stars for every role I
mean people from the housing authority
from the community organizer from the
designer from the management company I
don't think it was necessarily charisma
but it sure was a whole lot of
competence let's see if we can take the
last question with the microphone
overlock how do you see the role of
private affordable housing developers
such as Habitat for Humanity there there
is such a crying need for low-income
housing provision that everybody from
all sectors needs to to pitch in what I
would observe however is that nearly all
of the of what comes out of either
private or nonprofit sectors has failed
to reach those who are most at risk the
million people that are on housing
authority waiting lists around the
country often have incomes that are so
low
either through lack of employment or
minimum wage kinds of jobs often
multiple minimum-wage jobs where they
can't afford to live in the cities that
they are and my fear is that that most
of what goes on either through through
habitat or through the Community
Development Corporation world or even a
lot of the housing that's funded by
low-income housing tax credits which can
go up to 60% of median income is simply
not reaching the people who are at 15%
of of median income that are in public
housing so if you lose your spot in
public how
and that's happened to a hundred and
fifteen thousand units that have been
torn down by the federal government
during the last decade or so you don't
have an alternative we are going
backwards on the question of provision
of housing for very low income people
and I find that to be very disturbing
thank you very much
[Applause]
our next speaker is dr. Steven ansible
err he is a faculty member in the
Department of Political Science he was a
Carnegie scholar he won the goldsmith
Book Prize for going- how political
advertising divides and shrinks the
American electorate and he's been a
national fellow at the Hoover
Institution I have to tell you I'm
looking forward to this
he doesn't know my congressman is Chris
Shay's and I know Chris fairly well and
we've had conversations about this
subject and I am at the moment candidate
for First Selectman in my community
which is sort of like being mayor only
you don't have any power and I'm looking
forward either going negative or not
going negative depending on how things
work out so I'm here to take notes and
with that back there insel there
[Applause]
all right this is my book going negative
was written at night published in 96 and
this project that I'm going to talk
about today is really a follow-on to
that because the question coming out of
the study of political advertising in
the 90s that I did and that others did
was whether or not television and demand
for money to pay for political
advertising is having corrupting effects
and that's where Chris Shay's comes into
this and this project is really about a
transformation of my own thinking and I
suspect a transformation of other
people's thinking on this issue and it's
really at the intersection of law and
politics and economics where this
research is located let me tell you a
little bit about that transformation
which is that going into this project my
assessment my thinking my beliefs were
that television advertising costs we're
driving political campaign expenditures
along with corruption the things you had
to promise as a politician or to raise
money and the transformation gradually
and a lot of the facts were right
underneath my nose the entire time going
into this the transformation really came
out of an understanding that money is
more money in our society is more about
participation and that raised a
different set of problems and so I want
to sort of talk you around to that and
get you to the point where I hope you
understand least where I'm coming from
and maybe you even agree with me by the
end of this let me begin with a famous
equality in this area of thinking which
is money is speech now to most of us we
can think of some media problems with
this equation but this is the legal view
in the United States money is speech and
this came out of a famous court case
called Buckley v Valeo in 1976 where the
Supreme
made that equation and before then it
really hadn't ever made that equation
money is speech in this perspective in
two ways one is if you're a political
candidate or an organization or even an
individual who wants to spend money to
promote an idea
to campaign for office the government
cannot force you to limit the amount of
speech that you want to engage in it
can't arbitrarily or unilaterally limit
the total campaign spending in the
United States and that was what the
court threw out which was a provision in
the original federal elections campaign
Act limiting the amount of money that
congressional candidates spent for
elections in addition the court decided
that giving was a kind of speech if you
give money to somebody you're supporting
them you're endorsing them however they
didn't the court didn't go quite as far
in their view that money is speech with
respect to giving because they said that
there was also a government interest in
limiting corruption and against that
government interest we had to weigh our
our views of how we regulate
contributions behavior it's a difficult
con is it's a difficult line to draw and
it's what's before the Supreme Court
right now because last year the mccain
feingold bill passed and that was to
limit other kinds of campaign spending
and contributions and that raises once
again this thorny set of issues which we
seem to be continually thinking our way
through from a social scientists
perspective one question we should ask
is is money speech and there's been a
variety of research on this set of
laboratory experiments which is what I
did
in my earlier work relating the
advertising that one sees to whether or
not one supports a candidate whose
advertisements you saw and they're in
the laboratory you can produce a pretty
big effect of seeing just one political
advertisement there have also been a set
of field experiments done at you done at
Yale where they've sent
people out into the fields they've
gotten campaigns to agree to do this
well they randomly choose who's going to
get direct mailings who's not who's
gonna receive a canvasser and who's not
and it looks like it cost about $40 to
persuade somebody to vote hard to say if
it's whether or not they'll vote for you
and then there are what are called
observational studies just correlating
how much is spent with how well you do
in the election and that seems to
suggest something on the order of if you
double your spending say from 250,000 to
500,000 dollars you can increase your
vote share in a congressional campaign
by about five percentage points so there
doesn't seem to be this connection
between money and speech though I'm not
sure I would call it an equality I think
there's a fundamental ethical and
societal set of problems that we need to
think about and that the courts really
thinking about right now and that is
that everyone benefits from free speech
in our society everyone benefits from
campaign finance all of us why because
the fact that the candidate can go out
and advertise means that they're
creating a more informed electorate and
that's a public good so anybody who
votes can get information otherwise it's
very difficult to become informed about
what the choices are that face you in a
primer in a primary election especially
but in a candidate contest or in a an
initiative a referendum however and this
is the where the difficulty comes in
private financing of political campaigns
which is the way almost every advanced
democracy works make politicians more
attuned to the interests of donors and
that's where the difficulty lies as a
societal problem and I want to
distinguish a societal problem from a
legal or ethical problem as a societal
problem the question is how do we weigh
the gain that we all get from having
competitive informative elections
against the idea that maybe the people
who give money in some ways are getting
more weight in the society and we'll
come back to how that might work there
is a set of individual ethical problems
which have to do with the individual
relationship between the specific donor
and the politician which we might call
bribery and we will maintain bribery law
throughout no matter what the court
decides about
bipartisan campaign Reform Act versus
personal speech so if I'm an individual
politician or I'm an individual in this
society I want to have my speech and my
money is my speech well the US after
Buckley v Valeo still regulates
political campaigns and we regulate it
in a couple of ways the Federal
Elections campaign Act set down
contribution limits on individuals and
groups and parties and if you're an
individual you can give $1,000 in
election because there's a primary and a
general election that means that in an
election cycle and give $2,000 to a
federal candidate you can get a group
like a corporation that has a political
action committee can give up to $10,000
to a candidate and parties have a
different set of limits but they're
roughly comparable in presidential
campaigns we have public financing we
have two kinds of public financing in
the primary election we have matching
funds which has all sorts of interesting
implications you have to write any
candidate who raised a certain amount of
money can have that money matched in the
general election we have public
financing that's just an outright grant
and to either qualify for the grant or
for the matching funds you have to abide
by spending limits this is the only way
that the courts been willing to allow
spending limits in addition an
individual or a group can spend
independently and that's what are called
issue ads and go out and buy as many
issue as you want advocating a
particular issue and parties can spend
money in the state elections because
they're no longer Federal Elections and
that's called soft money that's what the
mccain feingold law went after at those
two issues the big question that
everyone's wondering about right now is
is the federal election campaign Act
failing is this system that was set up
in 1974 about to fall apart and so we're
going to go into an unregulated system
in 2000 election we spent about three
billion dollars on Federal Elections
that's every dollar I've been able to
uncover from any sort of odd loophole
and so forth it's roughly evenly divided
in the u.s. between congressional
candidates who spend about a billion
dollars and that's all within the limits
it's all legal money no no
loopholes parties who spent almost
another billion a little over another
billion most of which was hard money
that's legal that's under under those
contribution limits and then finally the
presidential system of which only about
240 million dollars came from the public
treasury and 500 million came from
private sources and here's the real
problem that people point to which is
this is the trend in campaign spending
relative to inflation since 1880 in the
United States and this is presidential
I've been able to accumulate a series of
presidential expenditures and that's
this graph with little dots on it going
up and it looks like this system is
about to come apart because the trend is
going up extremely fast this is since
1974 we've had some accounting of what
Congress spends and Congress is going up
as well and these are political action
committees these are interest groups the
worry then is that even with these
regulations we're not able to control
campaign spending and the resulting
issues of corruption so the fundamental
question that political scientists and
economists are grappling with right now
is why is spending growing why is
campaign spending growing and I just
want to say it parenthetically this is
not an American problem either every
democracy that we've been able to study
and every every state is witnessing the
same problems campaign spending growing
apparently without bound so the first
thing that social scientists have been
looking at since the 70s is corruption
is there a smoking gun out there is
there a relationship between donors
giving money to legislators and
legislators voting and the answer is if
it's out there it's extremely rare so
that we we've surveyed over 200 studies
that have been published and only one in
five of those studies report any
significant correlation and once you
control for the district's interest you
know the legislators right
the people that legislator represents
their interest there's no connection
between the donations they get and how
they behave in legislation either making
decisions in a roll call vote or terms
the final passage of legislation what
about TV this is probably the thing that
surprised me most in this investigation
this is total campaign spending
challenges and incumbents combined in
different congressional elections and
what we've done is grouped quintiles of
expenditures of districts so this is the
cost of airing ads in congressional
elections the fifth quintile is New York
and LA you pay $1100 per rating point in
LA the lowest quintile is like Alabama
and Montana you pay sixty two dollars
per quintile there's no correlation
between the cost of the rating point and
how much is spent which is when we saw
this or stopped us you know it stopped a
lot of researchers in their tracks
because this means that total campaign
expenditures are unrelated to TV costs
now this is for Chris Shay's this is a
pressing issue in the future because the
next piece of campaign legislation that
John McCain is sponsoring is to give
candidates free airtime and to regulate
campaign private TV advertising prices
to try to control campaign spending the
lesson here is this has nothing to do
with the rise of campaign spending or
the demand for interest group money why
is this true well this is best seen in a
little graph this graph shows those
quintiles along the bottom this is the
most expensive market this is the
cheapest market and this is the percent
that candidates are spending on TV and
on direct mail campaigns are like little
efficient firms if you face a very
expensive input price you substitute
into an ear substitute and in this case
its Direct Mail so as TV goes down as
you get in more expensive media market
and direct mail goes up
and there are other kinds of campaign at
communications
but the price or cost push inflation
doesn't really seem to bear out very
strongly the model that social
scientists seem to be concentrating more
on now is one in which we believe that
it's that giving is a form of political
participation even giving by
corporations there's a form of political
participation there have been some
excellent surveys of who gives why and
how much and it looks like a fairly
constant fraction you know United States
public has been giving to politics for
the last 25 to 30 years for which we
have survey data and that constant
fraction is about 8 percent 8 percent of
American public gives money to political
candidates those 8 percent
tend to be drawn disproportionately from
the upper income quintile and there was
a wealthiest quintile gives about 12
about 12 people from the wealthiest
quintile give for every person who's in
the lower and middle income quintile so
we have a fairly constant participation
rate when we study state elections to
get a little more leverage on what
explains the growth in campaign spending
we find that two things come out one is
income per capita strongly predicts how
much is spent in gubernatorial elections
and the closeness of the election so the
demand for money the size of government
is not related to how much is spent and
this is sort of something that's
predicted by economists who think that
government is there's a lot of
corruption or a lot of extortion that
underlies campaign spending and
therefore you'd expect that the size of
government would explain zhat amount of
money that was spent in fact it seems to
be more of just two things income per
capita and a closeness of elections and
I think that the main surprising thing
that we've uncovered and this is my
collaborators here at at MIT is that
when you take that same time trend of
how much is spent in US elections
and deflate it by not inflation which is
the purchasing power of the dollar but
GDP which is how much income there is in
a society you find that since the
nineteen forties roughly there's been
really no change in how much is spent in
u.s. elections spending grows with
income what changed is this era is a lot
different from what came after it and
that era was the era of political party
machineries in the cities the robber
barons and so forth this is a very
different political era than this era
out here and from this perspective it
does not look like after the Federal
Elections Campaign Act which is this
line right here 1974 there's any trend
at all in how much spending is growing
spending just grows with how much income
there is in society we've gone out and
looked at several other countries
England Sweden Italy all of them show
the same pattern income is a constant
fraction pain spending is a constant
fraction of the society this takes it
back to the fundamental question I think
is before the court right now today and
the fundamental question that really
motivated my own interest in this in
this problem which is is there a
societal problem lurking behind the
campaign finance question there really
the United States is debated since 1905
there are two ways to view the societal
problem one is that campaign finance
reflects the purchase of private
benefits for corporations and wealthy
individuals at the public trough and the
answer seems to be no the donations from
corporations donations from labor unions
donations from in wealthy individuals
are not buying private benefits such as
a specific tax loophole at least to any
significant amount and I think that the
most stunning way to think about this is
the amounts that I've shown you are
actually trivially small three billion
dollars as a fraction of government
spending
is nothing three billion dollars is a
fraction of our national income is
nothing and if we imagine that what was
going on was the sale of private
benefits which is the usual picture I
think that people have in their minds
when they think about campaign
contributions especially from
corporations and and wealthy individuals
then those private benefits would be
exclusive little benefits that you could
buy say it a subsidy for an industry if
that we're going on then you'd have a
nice little natural market and this
would be probably the best market to
invest in in America because the rate of
return would have to be enormous on
three billion dollars for this to amount
to any amount of societal problem so if
you believe that you can buy significant
private benefits I have one little
recommendation for you which is take
your money out of the stock market and
invest in a politician however we've
seen very little of that kind of
behavior there's a second societal
problem and it has to do with public
policy and that is that the fact that
you have a system of campaign finance
which draws disproportionately on
wealthy individuals means that the
wealthy individuals might have more
weight in the society and this is in a
sense campaign finance might be thought
of differently as weighted voting think
back to the one figure I told you which
is it cost about forty dollars to
mobilize someone to vote so if I gave
two thousand dollars or if I even gave a
hundred dollars I'd be worth two and a
half votes by that equation and if I
gave so the amount that I get is in
somehow translating not into speech as
the courts originally defined it but
maybe it's translating into votes and if
that's the case then we have a different
sort of problem on our hands one that
the courts have not really grappled with
and that is the idea that we have the we
have to weigh the issue of weighted
voting how much weight individuals in
our society have in a participatory
model of politics or a pluralist
Society and whether that sort of
behavior reflects the kind of
representation we want that is not the
question that the court has put before
us but it is a question of sort of
lurking out there and this is the
direction in which we're taking this
research at MIT and that is now not to
look at a set of small private benefits
that individual firms might get but to
look at the overall tax code while the
overall tax code is more or less
progressive or regressive it appears so
from this is very preliminary it appears
that there is a small but noticeable
effect of campaign giving in the States
on the progressivity of the tax code to
the tune of about a half a percentage
point in other words the Porat that the
rate that the upper income people is pet
or pay in terms of their income taxes
there's about half percent lower as a
result of about a dollar increase in per
capita spending in the States
I want to end there and just sort of
throw this open for some questions
mainly because whenever I talked about
this to a public forum the fundamental
quiet that the fundamental facts seem to
be a bit jarring and I'd like to just
hear what what you all have to say about
the nature of money in American system
in our American political system and
whether or not this is something we need
to fundamentally reform at this point
let's see if we can start on the far
side of the room and work our way back
over here wait for the microphone
because otherwise the people on the
outside can't hear you
the explanation California but your
corruption please balance out flying
formation
we're however a more serious nature what
about the money that union members pay
as individuals to the Union and then
they for instance in California the
teachers union is the largest single
contributor by millions of dollars over
anybody else and they have managed to
centralize all public education in
Sacramento and remove local control and
the result has been disastrous for
public education let me talk about the
price of a meeting first Terry McAuliffe
said at a meeting that I was at that you
know there's a price scheduled for the
time of President this was referring to
Clinton you know if you you can get a
photo for ten thousand dollars with a
group you can get a photo at your table
for twenty five thousand dollars so
forth so it is the case that money is
used to regulate politicians time
especially the more prominent
individuals whether that gets you
anything in return private Lee is a
different matter and a pretty
substantially different matter and
there's just extremely hard to find any
evidence of instances of corruption that
go beyond small-scale bribery right like
Kim in California is a classic case
union members are and for which we have
bribery laws and they're pretty
effective union members are an
interesting other issue and that is
classically what I'm talking about
that's taking a bunch of individuals who
are participating through their
membership in the Union and pooling
their resources the same is true of a a
corporation in the United States a
political action committee is not money
is not siphoning money out of the
corporate Treasury they're raising money
in from individuals within the firm so
it's a way of pooling resources the
Union members though tend to be middle
and lower-income and they are their
donations are outnumbered I said twelve
to one by wealthy individual
participation what the effective
teachers unions are on
public education so far that seems to be
a it's an another topic I don't think
that their power however comes from
their money I think their power comes
from the fact that they're organized and
they can walk out on strikes and that
has a much bigger effect on negotiations
and wages and the NLRB protects them and
so forth
so there are other the Union brings so
many other resources to bear on the that
that's what splaining their
effectiveness in terms of public policy
let's see if we can come back to this
side I'm curious is how do you draw the
connection between the the income tax
and the wealth of donors the income tax
changes there are a couple of
interesting case studies of the Tax
Reform Act of 86 where what was at stake
in the Tax Reform Act was whether we
should eliminate a bunch of corporate
loopholes and lower the marginal tax
rate or keep the marginal tax rate on
the upper income segments of society
high and keep those loopholes and in the
end when push came to shove it was
lowering the income tax rate rather than
keeping the corporate loopholes which is
an interesting statement and there was a
lot of evidence about the lobbying so
once people got in the door what did the
firms in the end lobby for they lobbied
for lowering the personal income tax
rate rather than keeping the private
benefits for the corporation so it's one
piece of interesting evidence and and
there are other bills that have had the
similar flavor where corporations when
push comes to shove prefer to pursue
their income classes interests the
immediate studies I was referring to
here take the broad panel of tax rates
in the states and relate that to the
total amount of spending in those states
over time within states so when when you
see a change in campaign spending over
time safe five-year interval and do you
see it
shift in the income tax subsequently and
you do know when there are other pieces
to look at such as Florida and a few
other states in Minnesota introduced
public financing once you remove the
private money what happens in those
states you saw an increase in
progressivity of the tax code so there
we're attacking this from a bunch of
different angles one from the
observational or aggregate data and also
from some sort of more focused case
studies if you have any thoughts what to
do you know I thought MIT was the only
school that gave an SB degree
apparently the University of Minnesota
does also yeah but at Minnesota it's BS
Minnesota's Bachelor of Science so it's
a BS I find your results very
interesting but I can't wrap my mind
around I can't come to believe it yeah
and I think the following way what if
the advocates of low-income housing had
as much money to spend as the advocates
of any income tax cut or or tax break
like the petroleum industry had to spend
wouldn't they be a lot more successful
than they are now if you gave if you
equalize the amount of money that was
given as a matter of participation then
yeah they probably would be because
that's a matter of weighted voting
however when you start looking at how
much corporations give it is remarkably
small the average corporate contribution
to a candidate to it to an incumbent is
$1,700 which is a in the scheme of
things a tiny male corporations total
gave in this entire picture all that
money three billion corporations total
in terms of their their hard money gave
giving and there's a giving to Congress
was 300 million so of the billion
dollars that Congress gave corporations
gave a small amount and I suspect that
that in and of itself means that
corporations see this is not a great
investment in the scheme of things it's
a small fraction of corporate revenues
if we equalize spending by not not
giving it to a group of public housing
advocates I think they would be as
effective as a corporation and their
ability to get things if we equalize
spending across income groups then I
think we would see some changes
we have a question over in the sun
following up with the with the question
of equalizing over income groups what
would be your response to making any
kind of private contribution or
corporate contribution completely
illegal and having the government
finance all campaigns as a public
collective good just like it does
national defense I'll put the national
defense issue aside don't want to get in
trouble with shark so the we do public
publicly financed general elections for
president and so there is some degree of
that already and we've seen we've we've
had an experience with that and the
problem is it's very difficult to
implement a public financing scheme
without things leaking through LEEP
loopholes or to find their way through
another organizational scheme if we were
to do something like that I think you'd
have to be extremely generous basically
you have to buy people out so there's
two completely remove the incentive for
them to misbehave in any way and when
that cut when you when you propose a
very generous system like that
the public just doesn't go for it
Massachusetts just went through a
five-year struggle over this and let me
briefly characterize it in 1998 we
passed a initiative which was to create
a publicly financed electoral system the
advocates of that system knew in advance
that there was no way that they could do
that pass that and tie it to any kind of
financing scheme like a tax that you'd
put in like a tax checkoff so they left
that off and that passed pretty
substantially when that meant that the
legislature had to pass a financing
scheme and when the legislature sat down
to pass a financing scheme they just
couldn't do it there was just too much
opposition within the Democratic Party
in particular to finance and Republican
opponents and this
failed so the Supreme Court of the state
eventually had to get involved in this
issue and their level of involvement was
down to or during the sale of the
furniture of the Speaker of the House to
pay for the system so the opponents of
this system put an advisory initiative
on this on the on the to the public in
2002 and that advisory opinion was if we
use taxpayer dollars to pay for public
to pay publicly for elections would you
support it and that one that lost
overwhelmingly to two-thirds
three-quarters against using taxpayer
money so the issue is the public will
not go for it they do people do not like
the idea of using taxpayer dollars to
pay for elections and I think that's
where we are I'm sorry I think we're
going to stop there we've we need to
take a break this is a subject that we
could all have fun with but standing
here it's making me extremely
uncomfortable all these sort of the the
underlying tone of this is politicians
are corrupt
is there gambling in Las Vegas
no that's fixed so they I would by the
way I was a an aeronautical engineer as
an undergraduate here and when the
newspaper found that out the headline
said rocket scientist runs for First
Selectman so with that we're going to
take a break there are refreshments out
in the lobby we'd like to have you back
at 11:00 so that we can continue to stay
on schedule and get you off to lunch
thank you very much
give you a second to
and that it's okay
she will speak briefly just before lunch
but she can probably speak here yeah so
are we up
all right
says John yes it does 1930
I assume it does yes yeah yeah I don't
know I don't know those people Bonnie
didn't know okay
yeah the memorial service yes I saw it
bad okay
we'll find out all right welcome back
if you'll take your seats we can get
restarted
this is always the hard part getting the
enthusiastic conversation to come to an
end
but we'd like to get started again if we
can thank you thank you I had the
opportunity to I try to settle down a
crowd about this size once a couple of
years ago then then past President Ford
was about to speak and I was standing at
the podium like this trying to get the
crowd to settle down and they weren't
nearly as helpful as you were they kept
right on talking and talking and finally
the Secret Service man who was standing
just to my side sidled up to me and said
would you like me to fire off a couple
of shots
which apparently is Secret Service humor
I don't this was this was a few years
ago I probably wouldn't have crossed his
mind today well our next speaker is dr.
Rudolf jaenisch who is going to talk
with us about mammalian cloning and stem
cell therapy problems and promise
dr. Janish is a distinguished member of
the faculty and a founding member of the
Whitehead Institute and I encourage you
to look at the material in the booklet
not much more can be said than that that
institution in combination with MIT has
led some of the most astonishing
research in the last decade so without
further ado dr. Yannick
[Applause]
thank you very much I very much
appreciate the opportunity to talk to
you about something very different
nobody heard this morning so we'd like
to do is to talk about some biological
issues which are well browned
doli the first mammalian animal cloned
by nuclear transfer it's about no six
years ago and when Dolly was reported
this raised a number of quite
interesting issues one issue which I
find still totally surprising is why
does it work in the first place
sometimes I think memory in cloning
raises other questions what is the
usefulness of this technology for
research for medicine for medical
application for biotech industry then
maybe the most controversial issue it
should be used this technology for human
in applications so I want to really in
the in the next thirty minutes or so
Huli address some aspects of these three
questions mostly from the biological
point of view so we know cloning works
we know this from the Raelians
and this israel the leader of this sect
of raelians who knows the life came from
by cloning from another star he has been
in front of his youthful and this bishop
posole who is the CEO of clonaid who
would know by the day by the week
clone people healthy but people are
getting so boring that even the press
doesn't mind anymore and there's another
aspect of this of the sect which makes
them probably interesting to many anyway
rail rail is a very imaginative guy he
got his ideas in 1970 when he was
abducted by UFO in the pyrenees and then
he got it and so he had very imaginative
things to say actually after September
11 which I really can't resist to show
you what he said that but he said that
human cloning will make terrorist
attacks inefficiently below the
judgement of the perpetrators so off he
said he must accelerate development of
human cloning technology because it will
terrorist attacks inefficient in the
future in deep in Phase three of cloning
will be reached the wonderful most
direct cloning of an adult
thanks to this growth persons will be
followed by regular downloading
personality memory expert to your PC
therefore when tragedy occurs this
information what primitive people used
to call the soul could be transferred to
the new clone so you would lose one day
when if but this is more important this
technology will allow also the cloning
of terrorists thus allowing us to try
them for their crimes
this way no suicidal attack would which
seeds perpetrate escape from justice
through death so what you have to do is
you have to identify the terrorist
before he does it make several copies
one can go to jail one going death Road
whatever you want to do so it's
obviously a very imaginative way of this
technology so let me come to the issues
what is what is cloning so there two
types of cloning one is molecular
cloning when you take a human gene for
example and multiply it in a bacterium
we know this since the 70s it's a very
important technology animal cloning in
the sense is the carbon copy a genetic
carbon copy of an individual so it has
identical genes as a donor let me
contrast the difference between the
conventional way of reproduction and
cloning so in a conventional way you
know that in the parents there's a
genetic exchange between the two
chromosomes they inherited from their
parents this is called meiosis as a
result of this every sibling has a
different combination of genes which
were present in the parents so every
sibling is seen new and genetically
unique life which will not exist has not
existed before and will never exist
again in cloning one takes cells of one
of these individuals and now generates
new individuals which of course all
identical
there's no meiosis no sperm or egg
maturation so these clones all identical
there's no novel gene combination it's
really
propagation of existing life from the
biological point of view it is not new
life I think that's important to realize
I will come back to this so cloning has
enormous problems it is extremely
inefficient the major problem is what we
call epigenetic regulation let me define
what it is
so Dolly was made from a cell of a
mammary gland so these nuclei of such a
cell are poised to express the genes
which are important for mammary gland
function that say milk production but
not the genes which are important for
embryonic development they are there but
they are silenced so what in cloning has
to occur after the nucleus is put into
the egg this adult pattern of gene
expression has to be converted to
sandwich is appropriate for an embryonic
one this is not a genetic change
it's called epigenetic because it
doesn't involve any change in sequence
so you give me were very simple so I
know that's a little bit for many of you
you will not appreciate what that means
let me tell you in a very simple example
what I mean and this is a text example
so you know this first paragraph e to be
or not to be that is the question and so
on you can read this very easily because
here spaces between the words the
punctuation and so on so forth let's
make an experiment let's take out all
the spaces and all the punctuation now
try to read the sentence it's much more
difficult this is exactly what
epigenetic does it makes streams
readable to the cell or non readable
there's no change in information content
with the same information content so
development occurs by making some of
these genes some of these sentences
readable that say in the mammary gland
the genes for milk production are
readable but the ones for embryonic
development are not in the early embryo
those genes are not readable but those
are so the problem of Dolly of cloning
is how you convert this epigenetic state
of this state of the genes to one which
is appropriate for the early embryo this
probably goes over some of those over
those stages so I could put well
hello terms on this what I mean with
this but I think that gives you the idea
so the problem of dolly then was that
the donor cell expressed the genes which
is important for mammary gland function
let's say those production look but not
those which the early embryo need so
they the transplanted nucleus must have
activate those genes and inactivate the
other ones and that's why it's the main
reason that this procedure is extremely
inefficient and the outcome is almost
always detrimental not normal so this is
the procedure so in normal fertilization
to gamuts a sperm in the neck they're
called haploid because I wanted a half
the set of genes are combined to give
rise to what's called a diploid zygote
or early embryo Gene's come from father
and for mother in cloning and removes
the nucleus from the egg into replaces
with the diploid nucleus which comes
from a body cell so you get it deployed
clone now they have eight species now
I've been cloned in mammals in most
cases this is done mechanically and this
is done by electro fusion you just
refuse the cell that works quite
efficient in some species very
inefficient in others we work with Mouse
at the Whitehead Institute Mouse is the
most difficult one to clone and is this
only possible by really by a mechanical
way to to to transfer this nucleus in
the student my laboratory
Kevin egg was really probably one of the
most proficient cloners in the country
he took the movie which I'm going to
show you to make you appreciate what is
involved in this nuclear transfer in
moss so this is the first as the a
nucleation step where you see here the
egg to be enucleated this is the
nucleation pipette and you go in and you
suck out what's called the metaphase
spin of the nucleus of the egg there it
is and this is actually that's a pipette
to immobilize the egg so he has to he
has to orient the egg in a way that I
mean the nucleus spin which you can very
difficult to see faces the pipette
energy has to go through this egg shell
with this pipette and then take out
the nucleus there it is so the next step
would be then the preparation of the
donor nucleus but you see there's a very
small pipette which is smaller this is
hell you suck up the cell up and down
this pipe and you disrupt the
cytoplasmic membrane so what's left over
is and their nucleus which is not
disrupted you can see the nucleus is no
sucked into the pipette and you leave
behind the corpse of the of the of the
cell in the next step then is the
transfer of this nucleus into the
enucleated egg and you will see now
again this has to be mobilized the egg
it's a very high magnification you know
he's expelling no will be no expelling
the nucleus the nuclei in the pipette
that comes you know you very deeply
insert this movie into the cytoplasm you
insert one nucleus into one egg that is
okay
so this is really the transfer of a
diploid nucleus into the nucleated egg
to generate gained a diploid and diploid
a cloned embryo which has two
complements of chromosomes I'll show you
one more here so this is a done under
very high magnification it looks very
easy it is not so the next step then was
take these cloned embryos it would
incubate them in a salt solution and
they're divided make a two cell embryo
then what's called sixteen cell embryo
in the blastocyst the bust is about 30
cells and these blastocysts then in
humans it would be about hundred cells
there would no implant into the uterus
of the mother and you wait them and then
the other end comes out Dali at a later
age clone Mouse pigs a cat cows and
there's a new and there's some other
species so what is the problem the
problem is it's extremely inefficient
because we believe a faulty
reprogramming not resetting the genes
which are important for early
development in for later stage
development
so most clones just died right after
implant
the blasters goes in the uterus in dice
few survived to birth but have made many
series of normalities in my diet just
after birth even fewer become apparently
normal adults and I really emphasize
apparently I'll show you an example of
such a clone most very often when called
talks about the large offspring syndrome
this is a newborn Mouse a clone which
about four times the size of a control
is a monster it didn't survive the
placenta is very abnormal much bigger
than normal to Center so this is typical
for all species that are very large at
birth their problems many die they can't
resk
and initiate respiration but some then
recover and look normal
are their normal it's a very important
question so when you look at such an
animal you think there must be something
wrong with genes genes are not correctly
expressed so we tested that and when you
test in such an animal let's say the
expression of 10,000 genes then we find
that hundreds of the genes in the animal
which looks normal are not correctly
expressed we believe probably xx of the
genome that's a lot so from this I would
argue there may be even not normal
clones all clones even if they appear
normal may not be really normal but they
never they do appear are they this is a
very controversial issue particularly
some biotech companies believe because
their cows sitting on the fields a CT is
one you close to Boston there must be
normal they look at them to prove it
they look they have a heart yes I have a
heart they have serum just have serum
and then they go through there must be
normal and it's published in science so
this is a very superficial way of
looking at it and most one can do this
much better and the cruelest are the
hidden defects which you don't see when
you just look at an animal and they are
this only has been possibly doing mice
because of although these animals appear
quite normal up to one year of age
suddenly when you age them they really
died much earlier with major abnormality
so you pay a price when you shortcut
sperm at your age like maturation in
photos
and this is a study here which came out
last year and I show you this one here
where they looked at the survival curve
of cloned animal plotted against th two
normal ones you can see the clone ones
died much only a year earlier it's 30%
of lifespan then control animals and
when you looked at them why do they die
they have major optimality and many many
tissues nevertheless they appeared quite
norm actually totally normal and their 1
year of age so there's some hidden
defect which no you need time to come
out so either you die early but even the
survivors are not good and may have
really serious problems but it's
important the problem on season clones
is epigenetic it's not genetic genetic
means change of sequences and we know
that for sure because if a cloned animal
can produce a mature gamete a sperm or
an egg the offspring is always normal so
there's no genetic change which would be
passed it is really this reprogramming
which is of course important for the
biotech industry I mean they're not
going to eat their clones they're gonna
eat the offspring the offspring is of
course normal so I think it's a it's
very important to realize the difference
between epigenetic in genetic genetic
means change in gene structure and
sequence mutations epigenetic does not
mean this it is reversible so of course
cloning is very closely sort of
connected with embryonic stem cells and
their potential so what are embryonic
stem cells the M&M stem cell derived
from these blastocysts I showed you and
curiously enough it only works in human
and mouse but that works quite
efficiently now these cells can
differentiate in culture to almost any
cell type of the body to neurons to
muscle to blood to bone anything in
principle and we're learning how to do
that so what is the potential of these
cells I think the potential for medicine
is for transplantation medicine so an
embryonic stem suck as I said can give
rise to blood cells to neurons to beat
ourselves actually all cells of the body
and we know the potential medic medical
applications in include treatment of
parking zone diabeetus of blood diseases
of leukemia patients many others is
there any evidence that this would work
in the first place
well transportation medicine there's
solid evidence that if you put into
cells normal cells on to patients
suffering of Parkinson or diabetes for
example in Parkins on those cells which
die dopaminergic cells you can help
these patients recover very much of
their function this is solid evidence
the problems where do you get the cells
the cells come from aborted fetuses and
for example to treat one side of a
patient he needs 6 brains of a fetus in
for example for diabetes that come from
corpses from from dead people so the
problem is in this conventional
transplantation listen its first of all
it's in unary rejection you have to
treat these patients to reject - to
avoid rejection but I think the major
problem is availability of cells you
can't get enough fetuses and the quality
control there's no quality control here
that's a really problem but if you could
make a monic stem cells do you have as
many cells as you want and you can
control the quality um and if you do it
from a patient you would avoid immune
rejection because it comes from the same
patient so let me tell you what such an
experiment would look like it's an
experiment we did because people argued
it doesn't work anyway so we thought in
most we just so see could it work so
instead pretty cloning combined with
gene therapy what you would do is you
would take a somatic nucleus from a
diseased patient for example and the
revive derive an embryonic stem cell by
nuclear transfer as I showed you you
could use actually these cells to
correct a genetic defect which might
have be the cause of the disease then
you have to in vitro in the culture dish
differentiate the cells that are
repaired cells and finally transplant
those back to the patient and see
whether it helps
so we choose as inevitably one example
is a patient or mouse which lacks the
dream which is call direct to which
doesn't matter but if you don't have
that dream you're sort like a Bubble Boy
these are these children who are born
without an immune system so they have to
live under Bubble to avoid avoid any
infection you know this but some of
these boys were treated no the gene
therapy in France and so what this gene
really normally does it is important for
that peripheral being T cells is their
lymphoid cells which fight infections
they're not present in these animals so
we thought this is all patient and I
show you just what it involved it's an
eight step procedure so this is the
patient the most the bubble Mouse if you
want and you take skin cells from this
from this animal and you make a nuclear
transfer with a nucleus of this put them
in an egg generate a blastocyst as I
showed you this plus SS will be no
converted to an embryonic stem cell this
is of course is mutant like the patient
so now you can use what we call
homologous recombination just to repair
the defect it's a trivial operation it
works so repair the defect you make a
embryonic stem cell they just no can
express this mutant gene then you have
to differentiate those cells to what's
called hemolytic stem cells put them
back and indeed the most nor can make B
in T cells and becomes immune competent
so in principle that works in a model
system it works quite clearly so when we
think about the two possibilities of
therapeutic cloning and gene therapy we
have two routes we have the one of what
we call therapeutic cloning where you
take my patient cell generate an Emer
neck stem cell you could correct the
gene defect you could then differentiate
those cells put them back and it will
work in some instances we have shown it
the alternative which you probably read
a lot about is somatic stem cells so
Matic stem cells are cells which are
taking from an adult organism and which
many people there's a lot of hype in
this field now which many people claim
and believe that you take a stem cell
from the bone marrow it could
make neurons and maybe liver cells a lot
of publications of course would be very
nice if we could do this because there
would be no ethical problem you wouldn't
need eggs and for the transfer the
problem is this is a very young field
and much of the evidence which has been
published has alternative
interpretations and I believe there's
really no clear evidence which is
convincing that says you can indulge in
the trans differentiate the bone marrow
cell and something else which is not a
blood cell so I would argue there's lots
of question mark see how to use those
potentials there it's very interesting
if you need much more research and with
the exception of bone marrow stem cells
there's no sulfur no evidence that they
useful for therapy so many argue because
the potential of these cells they don't
have to do this research and I think
that's wrong I think we need to do in
both areas very active research because
this one we know will work and this has
promise and this is a very young field
this is an established field the stem
cells we know that for 20 years where is
this feed we know for a few years two or
three okay so I would conclude then that
what's called SCN teeth to avoid
therapeutics loaning this somatic cell
nuclear transfer it's for research of a
therapeutic purposes I think it will
work it will it has worked and mouse it
will work in humans there are only
technical and no principle barriers to
do that if you have to learn how to do
the gizumon cells whereas in the
reproductive cloning as I will tell you
in a minute
they are principle barriers to do that
and I think this will be very important
so what we have to do is we have to to
adopt the methods which have been used
now in the mouse which we know the
system very well if you have to adapt
this to human cells and this is very
active research going on although of
course no nuclear transfer but learning
how these stem cells can differentiate
to neurons and beta cells of the
pancreas and so on
so there two questions one is
reproductive cloning could it be is it
can we think about that this could be
made a safe procedure as safe as in
vitro fertilization could we think there
should be a human a an acceptable
an acceptable technology of human
reproduction and I'm not going to go to
the evidence but if I told you you lot I
believe not
we have principal biological barriers
here which I find very difficult to
imagine how we can overcome them in the
foreseeable future and this is coming
from much understanding we have know
particularly in cloning of mice and of
course my son mammals and humans are
mammals so there's no reason to assume
that humans are different from mice in
this principle biological problems no
does this does this pose a problem for
therapeutic application and I believe it
does not because in therapeutic
application we make an embryonic stem
cell by cloning and we don't make a
fetus this embryonic stem cells is put
in the in the Pedro dish and in one step
we make neurons and the cells we want
but no fetal development if we know all
these streams which I mentioned these
hundreds of genes which are not
correctly expressed they important for
fetal development but not for the many
of the functions we seen in adult cell
so there's one of the reasons why I
believe he is no principal problem it's
his best a technical problem so I would
conclude then that is unlikely if not
impossible to create a normal individual
by nuclear cloning that's very important
some people disagree with this those
people who clone humans or claim to do
this they would even disagree I think
they're distorting the evidence so the
problems of reprogram may not be
solvable for the foreseeable future I
think their principle as opposed to
technical barriers to do reproductive
cloning but emmonak stem cell the right
form a clone embryo have the same
potential for tissue appear as those
from the fertilized embryo so the
question was you have a cloned and if
stem cell from a cloned embryo is it
less worth than stem cell from a
fertilized embryo and they are very hard
evidence there's no difference it's
important to realize so the question so
what I would argue yes cells which I
have been derived from an in-vitro
fertilized embryo which was not
implanted has the same potential for
therapy as one from a cloned embryo
so there are two types of nuclear
cloning there's some productive cloning
the purpose is to create a person
there's therapeutic cloning the purpose
is to create an embryonic stem cell
which is really tailored to the needs of
the patient you can conserve the source
for tissue repair so both approaches
involve the transfer of the somatic
nucleus into the egg and develop into
the blastocyst stage in reproductive
cloning the embryo is implanted into the
uterus in therapeutic cloning the
embryos explanted into a petri dish
that's a difference so what have you
learned from animal cloning when you
think nobody should it be tried for
humans I think we have learned that even
clones that survive to birth and look in
the end longer have series of the
mellitus and died later I showed you the
evidence a little bit of the evidence
and it's due to widespread epigenetic
dysregulation so I would argue most
clones may have at least subtle
abnormalities and I should argue really
if you look at mouth of one year of age
you don't know what the brain function
of this is right I mean this is we just
these animals or cows clone cause
they're not suitable to look at those
functions which are probably even more
important than looking at liver function
which we of course we can measure I
think this is all very difficult to
assess but I would argue they have even
major more problems I think they'll be
very interesting to clone primates but
it has not worked there major technical
problems I believe so I would argue that
normal clones if they exist may be the
absolute exception but this doesn't
really frighten some people some people
think this is a bad idea to clone people
like these two sheep would think it's
disgusting
but other two things a good idea like
Savas this fertility doctor from from
Kentucky who in April said they clone no
human embryo which was 8 cells is not a
big deal
and made a big fuss about this but this
is particularly interesting what the
artist is he can use he can you can
scream premeditation embryos by genetic
means to read all the good ones from the
bad ones this is a cereal
distortion of all scientific evidence
it's a misleading of all the evidence
because what he argues is that he could
use prenatal diagnosis which is
routinely used in a clinic and this is
used to detect chromosomal aberrations
for Down's syndrome fetus for example or
known genetic defects which are known to
be present the parents does if he does
have it
it's a terrific method to do this but
the problems and clones as I told you
it's not genetic it's epigenetic and
there's no way no way you can test
30,000 genes for any epigenetic this is
just the problems we all can do it for
one gene in the laboratory so this is a
gross misstatement of all the evidence
so it says clearly at present there's no
way to predict whether given clone for
the develop into a normal or abnormal
individual and so I think it's really
very misleading but unfortunately these
guys are very vocal some people believe
so for example this guy doc dawn or 35
years old was quoted I would not mind
being the first person cloned I don't
mind being a guinea pig now here's a
normal confusion it's enormous confusion
right who's a guinea pig here the one
who gives who gives the cell or what so
I think it's unfortunate this is
distorted by often by media coverage and
by these I think very irresponsible
people I exam us and antenori and these
clones the Raelians I don't count
anymore recipe to take serious so there
a couple of ethical issues now when does
life begin which is of course a very
important issue and I believe as a
biologist biologist you have to say it
begins with fertilization I can't say
anything else I think that's not the
issue the issue is when it's an embryo
person that is the issue I think the
extreme views some belief and Embree has
human status at the moment of
fertilization in others belief no only
much later maybe is a newborn which I
think more the Jewish philosophy were to
put argue or some human leave maybe only
when the children leave the house so it
what
but what I'm trying to argue is here
there's no way no scientific way to
argue when is an embryo a person really
there must be other we can to
scientifically this so the British made
sort of a compromise they say the early
embryo really deserves special status as
a potential human being but at the very
early stages during cleavage up to the
blastocyst age this can be weighed
against other potential benefits for
society or therapy right so I'll come
back to this so this is the human plus
assist 100 cells when you implant and
will give rise to a fetus and explain
the trigger rise to an embryonic stem
cell
so some few issues which you hear often
discuss for example life begins with the
conception its fertilization now clearly
in cloning there is no conception there
is no fertilization it is in the
biological sense it's not a new life
it's a propagation of existing life the
fertilized egg has already individuality
yeah it probably has genetic
individually but certainly not anything
else we know this splitting and memory
gives you two different certainly the
identical twins with very different
personalities and actually two embryos
might fuse which probably some of you in
this room are derived from a few
stammers I don't know that right in
there of course I've only one
personality it's something which happens
normally I think the real problems to my
mind are these here the moral issues for
producing embryo and human eggs
yes enormous market for this the
commercial pressure and I think this is
really of big trouble some and I will
give you one potential answer for this
and then other people are very concerned
that this is a slippery road if you
believe if you below this step of the
cloning it's a slippery road to cloning
people so let me come humor these from
my point of view address some of these
issues so one is the through boutique
application nuclear transfer requires
large numbers of human eggs I think this
is the problem it's a major problem how
do you do this how do you and if it
circumstances really get them is that an
insurmountable problem now there's a
recent paper came out in science few
weeks ago where they said they're argue
that they can derive
all side like cells from embryonic stem
cells now that looks pretty interesting
it's not an old site yet but it looks
sort of interesting on the way
so if functional all sites could be
produced in tissue culture for monomeric
stem cell it may be possible to to
generate these recipient eggs you need
for transfer without asking a woman to
don't donate the eggs in tissue culture
in a generic cell I that were very
interesting but we are far away from
this at this point but I think it's a
technical issue to solve I think it will
work but we're not there at all so I
think one of the key concerns against
their boutique application of nuclear
transfers for example also voiced and
the in the bioethics Commission of the
president headed by leon kass is that
the duration of embryonic stem cells by
nuclear cloning necessitates the
destruction of potential human life i
think that's a major concern and then
for many of course becomes an abortion
issue which really has nothing moved
abortion but i think it becomes so let
me come to this issue here so there two
ways so if he if you think about where
do humans emmerich stem cells which have
been reduced so far where do they came
from they came from left over in vitro
fertilization breeze which were not
implant it right so the intent of
generating such an embryo was to
generate a baby clearly it wasn't needed
it wasn't implanted it was always a
creation of new life it's a unique
genetic combination it is a high
potential to generate a normal baby no
doubt in therapeutic cloning the intent
is not to generate a baby but it
tailored cell for cell therapy it is
problem as I said before it's a
propagation of existing life there's
nothing genetically new and I think most
importantly has a very low potential to
ever create a normal baby I argue this
all along most of those will be abnormal
so if it put is in a very simple
conclusion there are three possibilities
which are faced by embryo which is
leftover which was not implanted left
from in vitro fertilization a couple of
hundred thousand in this country or from
a cloned embryo it could be disposed it
could generate a normal baby
if implanted or it could generate a
normal embryo neck stem cell
four cloned embryo you have also three
possibilities it could be disposed could
generate a normal embryonic stem cell or
an abnormal baby if anything so when you
think about in this country most people
believe instead of throwing away these
embryos you might as well use them for
research or for therapy this is
acceptable but you do destroy a
potential human life it's no doubt about
if you accept this I wonder this should
be much easier to accept because there's
no potential to generate a normal baby
so I find at least from my point of view
if you accept that this poses might be
in less ethical problems so I would
argue then if you think about what's the
difference between a fertilized and the
clone embryo the fertilized embryos
created by conception it's unique it's a
high potential develop to normal babies
the cloned embryo there's no conception
no genetic new genetic combination it's
a product of a laboratory sister
technique it's not a natural event
there's little or no potential to ever
develop to a normal baby so I would
think between these two embryos the
clone Embree does lack some essential
qualities which be sort of associated
with a normal beginning normal human
life I think so I think the point I'm
gonna make us but shouldn't they create
those too so from the biological point
of view then the duration of embryonic
stem cells by nuclear cloning involves
the destruction of an embryo I think
that lacks the potential to ever develop
into a normal human being with any
acceptable efficiency so
have sort of made a compromise as I said
before there have a law which makes
reproductive cloning a criminal offense
and allows therapeutic cloning so of
course both involve the transfer of a
somatic nucleus under the egg and the
generation of a clone blastocyst the
dividing line is very clear you implant
you go to jail you don't implant-- you
don't go to jail this is not a grey zone
this is not a slippery road as far as
I'm concerned you either planned or you
don't you can't have implant right so I
think the slippery road argument in this
case it's also enforceable it's clearly
because you know you implant oh you
didn't
and the argument from the Justice
Department is saying we can't enforce we
can't punish woman who doesn't plan
another doctor and I think then you
change the law so you can enforce it so
I think so I think this is really I'm at
least biological it makes sense to do
this insert enforceable there's not a
slippery road I think slippery road
would be if you say you allow it to
manipulate an embryo for 14 days you
make a time limit and it turns out maybe
three weeks is better maybe four weeks
is better and you slip or you don't
to go further on I think implantation is
yes or no black or white the problem is
I think are these characters here so
these are they I should show you before
there's special puzzle game from clone 8
this Israel this is under nori this
fertility doctor from from Italy who
does this and this is no here rail in
his spacesuit testifying in the United
States of Congress this is and this is
again Davos and Beausoleil testing in
the United States of Congress and I'm
afraid these people what they do is but
they're distortion I think they're
really effect I think put the
legislation as we see it developing and
I think part of this is that certainly
our administration believes anything
which has to do with embryos or emmerich
stem cells is very suspect I think is
probably driven partially by this these
rather and irresponsible people that
like I showed you and that one's close
really with where some of the
legislation which is no passed in the
house which is the bells stupid bill
which was passed twice
and the underlying philosophy I think
it's regardless of its ultimate destiny
all human memories Arsenal taneous Li
human beings I think this is if you
believe that I think you should have a
problem you must have a problem with
many of these things so it led to an
interesting paragraph is so prohibition
of human cloning
so tell me unlawful for any person and
so on so forth to perform our tenth
perform human cloning to participate in
such an attempt to ship or receive any
clone embryo but this is really
interesting paragraph importation it
shall be unlawful for any person or
entity public or private knowingly to
import for any purpose in Embree
produced by human cloning or any product
derived from such an embryo now this is
pretty extreme if you think about it if
a patient that's say in this country
goes to England in case they get to take
knock technology established and gets
this TR diabetes treated let's assume so
they would arrest him at Boston Airport
because he would carry a product to
write from such an embryo but either cut
it out I'll put him into jail and the
big fines for that so I think it's a
very extreme bill which criminalizes
research which I think was sort of the
first in this country but I think it's
driven in part by by unfortunately by
these this publicity from from these
renegade people now this bill has passed
twice in the House and the Senate is
debating it and at this end it's not
clear what's gonna happen there's an
alternative bill in the Senate which is
more closer to the one like this and the
other one is more closer to the British
bill it's not clear what will happen I
think so let me close just acknowledging
some people of people my group who led
to much of the research which I talked
about the basis which is my cloning
group here and this is really mostly
students this is Kevin again I showed
you a movie from him he is one of the
early people who introduced the
technology for me there are three other
students and a postdoc who Lee made much
of the work I talked about and which we
take up the basis for our scientific and
assessment of this technology so thank
you very much for your attention
so we have time for a few questions see
if we have some hands hear something
funny
no questions aside from the political
issue if therapy or therapeutic abortion
there appeared ik cloning has been and
has been known for twenty years
why have we seen little or no success in
the curing of a disease such as cystic
fibrosis where the defective gene has
been known for I think Oh about 15 years
so cystic fibrosis it's much more
difficult than let's say a blood disease
the problem cystic fibrosis the cells
which are give you the simulant are the
linings of the lung and there have the
problem this this is transporters not
it's defective that's why you get these
infections in the gut now to replace by
cell therapy the cells of your lung
lining that's a very difficult issue
so transplantation medicine works very
well the bone marrow disease because
it's put in the bone marrow and the
cells distribute wherever they have to
go it works reasonably well let's say
for pancreas for for diabetes because
you have the beta cells they put them
anywhere let's say under the kidney
capsule also and they will work for
parking lots very interesting you know
where the cells have to be which are
dying at the parking zone patient you
buy stereotactic injection just deposit
these cells into this area and they
produced it open dopamine which is
lacking and there I think it's amazing
they improve enormous Lee the the
quality of these people of life and
their function so I think
transplantation medicine yes you can
replace a heart if you have the right
donor but you cannot make a heart and
culture no way you can do that but you
could make heart cells in culture can
inject them in a damaged heart it has
been shown to repair some of the defects
so the problem there two for two
problems and transplantation medicine
one is to have the cells
and have them have the immune problems
taken care of and the other one is
delivery and for some diseases delivery
is a real problem
cystic fibrosis would be one where I
think delivery of this sounds for the
right spot is a real problem go to the
next section
why are placental stem cells never
mentioned as a source a percent of stem
cell is a very new development so those
are stem cells which give rise to the
placenta lineage it's a very different
lineage from the embryo lineage into the
central stem cells they're very likely
and not very useful for replacing
somatic tissues they are known to rule E
quantum e to the percenter but not to
the embryo and of course when we want to
treat a patient we don't treat the
person that we want to treat the somatic
organs so this is a very interesting
cell line but it's probably not useful
for any therapeutic purposes hi Paul
Landsman how you doing
question is what do you think about
animals transportation no transporting
animal lungs and hearts into humans you
think that's going to be a possibility
someday and another question is we won't
hold it to you but how would you invest
in this exciting field of biotechnology
sorry can you repeat the last question
how would you invest in this field of
biotechnology we won't hold you to it of
course okay so the first question is you
need a donor animal and two people what
people believe is the best stone animal
would be a pig because pigs and humans
have some lot of similarities anyways so
so the problem is in pigs is this what's
called the acute rejection so the pig
has a certain there's a certain protein
on it cells on the cells which are right
away target for actually for serum and
humans say this if you transfer pixels
in the human they're destroyed within 20
minutes it's called the hyperacute
rejection now this has been or done this
they're knocked out their dream in pigs
so now you have pigs which don't have
this protein anymore so then you
transplant some tissue from those pigs
to you there would not be rejected by a
hyper immune hyperactive rejection went
to right away now come all the other
problems of xenotransplantation and
their series so are they solvable
some people believe yes you just have to
replace the immune system of pigs and
make it humanized or whatever maybe I
mean this is the future and I think
cloning helps you to do this so I think
there's a potential to do that but I
think they're very far away from this
now investing I think so there's a
couple of companies who were built on
stem cell technology on this one right
as you know and I think they have a very
hard time now in this investment climate
because of the I part of this is I
certainly is a political situation that
people believe it's a hot potato if you
work with human embryonic stem cells
it's a hot potato
how can you attract anyone I think
that's a reality to this so I think
that's problem at the moment it would be
not a good idea I think to invest in a
company with things they could generate
these cells for transplantation using
human embryonic stem cells for that but
that's my very humble point of view of
of investment strategy let's come back
over those
hello I'd like to know if you could give
a brief overview of the use of
retroviral insertion of genes in gene
therapy yeah so this is this what's this
tragedy I mentioned so there were ten
bubble boys which similar to almost
fight they didn't have being t-cells in
France because of a single gene defect
and what he's referring to is is a
therapy which looked very good it took
the cells the blood cells from these
boys or these children and transduce
using a retrovirus this dream and they
put them back into these boys it was
amazing
they got like almost they may be in T
cells and they were really in a way to
cured it was the real first success
story of gene therapy the problem came
up and they waited longer because three
of these children got leukemia why did
they get leukemia I worked my life with
retrovirus that's why I know these
things went well because we struggled
with us the virus you put in in such a
Cell can integrate anywhere in the
genome in many different positions and
what happened in these three children
leukemia the virus had integrated into a
gene which is known it's called an
oncogene which is known when activated
gives rise to these leukemias so the
virus activated their dream as a result
of its randomly getting into the in the
genome so the crisis is at random
actually it's a major questions of
interest and I think looking at 3 out of
10 you have to look how many
integrations took place and all these
calculations have to be made it may not
be around there might be preferential
integration sites for this virus and
that's of course is an acceptable risk
which these researchers did not know and
I think they right away went to the
public and they did the right things and
say it was very unexpected but very
troublesome so I think gene therapy with
an agent which you can't you don't know
where it ends up has an inherent risk
and that what is he said the gene
therapy I talked about where we take my
neck stem cells and nobody repair the
the mutated gene with homologous
recombination there's almost no risk
because you prepare to check whether you
did what you thought your dad did you
can test in culture and there's nothing
wrong with this because you can test
everything and he put this back to the
to the patient this is a very different
type of approach then you but you cannot
use this approach for adult stem cells
but let's say for for bone marrow stem
cells because they're so rare one in
hundred thousand cells is a bone marrow
stem so you can't grow these you can't
do this manipulation you can only use a
virus which infects everything and then
you select the right cells out you never
know what you did so that's a big
difference between these two types of
approaches of gene therapy one last
question
yeah very here in front get a microphone
anyway
you spoke a bit about how there are
hundreds of thousands of IVF cells that
are that are out there in the u.s. right
at the moment and I was curious under
the existing law and climate what is
acceptable use for these cells and
what's happening with all of them so I
think the the law says it's not
criminalized I think you need clearly
parental consent that's very important
right and that I think people believe
who only want to get this on an owner on
a solid footing they shouldn't be
commercial rewards for this make sure
you read the commercial aspects should
be taken out of this
I think the fate of this Emer is pretty
much a nimble because I think many
clinics don't know what to do with them
because either they get the permission
from the parents to destroy those they
don't have there might be a suit for
whatever so I think it's a very
unsettled situation of those of these
hundreds of thousands of embryos in
which I know
and we have it just a couple more things
to take care of first it's my pleasure
to introduce kimberly in francis who
chaired the committee that organized
these events kim
[Applause]
laughs distinguished Speakers alumni
parents students friends welcome my name
is Kim Francis I'm a member of the class
of 1978 and TechEd a chair for 2003 and
what a program we've had this morning
have a week on behalf of myself and the
Technic committee I want to thank my
sincere and preached appreciation for
all the speakers who gave up their time
and their Saturday to come in and
discuss these important topics fast
times at MIT we've learned much to learn
about ourselves and our choices as we
move into some of these very complex
technological applications and I
encourage the audience to continue your
learning by visiting the website
visiting this the speakers pages and
viewing their publication of course a
program of this magnitude cannot be put
together without a lot of dedication
from several support teams I'd like to
recognize the members of the technical
tech day committee I'm gonna read off
their names and would you stand Barbara
Greenberg 77 Keith McKay 97 Kim hunter
86 Leon cat 64 Bill leech 56 Holly
Schmidt 87 David stork 76
Sarika vittala 96 Doug Vincent 89 and
Marvin Grossman 51 thank you all
we challenged each other kindly and
gently under the guidance of Elizabeth
Durant and the Alumni Association office
and I want to thank her and her staff
for helping us
Tech Day is a very special day in the
MIT community you all have come back
here several years I would like to
invite you in order for us to continue
to improve this event to fill out a blue
evaluation form they're available in the
lobby and there's also boxes to drop
them in in the lobby so that we can
continue to bring the best of topics to
you we also have two more speakers after
lunch so I will ask you to return
promptly at 2 o'clock for the beginning
of the afternoon program at this time I
give you back to Jim lash for another
presentation we have one piece of
official business to do and to do this I
need bill Hecht to come up here
yesterday at at the meeting of the board
of your Alumni Association the board
voted the following resolution in
recognition of Bill's part-time
retirements whereas the honoree has
presided over the Alumni Association
longer than anyone else besides Ellen
swallow Richards husband and whereas as
director of the educational council he
first displayed to his MIT co-workers a
taste and capacity for airline travel
that amazes ordinary mortals and that no
doubt partly reflects the passion for
flying and aircraft which once found him
teaching an association president how to
tell 727s md-80s and other jet liners
one from another whereas he oversaw the
association qualit quintupled its gift
total shows its first woman president
made friends with resource development
successfully spun off Technology Review
set an unprecedented string of
fundraising records and showed its peers
nationwide the right way to put your
organization on the Internet
and whereas the honoree possesses the
exquisite flair for diplomacy required
of anyone whose job description says
that you
must serve three masters and that you
can assume they will rarely if ever be
in complete agreement with each other
and query as he knows by face and name
so many thousands of MIT graduates that
some may wonder how there can be room
left in his cranium for his encyclopedic
knowledge of topics from Alvar Aalto to
the zester center not to mention an
astonishing store of non MIT knowledge
and where is his affection for his alma
mater is deep and palpable as reflected
in his lengthy hours on the job his
vigorous representation of the interests
and views of the Alumni his unstinting
service as adviser to generations of
lucky freshmen and his richly deserved
bronzed beaver and whereas he extends
that same type of loyalty to friends and
family the latter including a group of
grandchildren who are growing up
understanding better than most the
concept of deep grandfatherly devotion
and whereas he has been described by a
prominent alumna as quote one of the
most huggable men you could ever hope to
meet
unquote it is therefore with profound
gratitude that we hereby congratulate
and command William J Hecht proud member
of the MIT class of 1961 for his past
present and future service to the
Massachusetts of Institute of Technology
this resolution voted by the Board of
Directors of the association of alumni
and alumni of the Massachusetts
Institute of Technology on this sixth
day of June 2003 you can say something
that we want
thank you
I would like to say just a couple of
words one of them is that each of you in
this audience represents 10 or 100 other
individuals alumni and alumnae spouses
friend that it has really been a
privilege to serve my good friend Paul
Gray has a wonderful phrase about MIT he
refers to it as this special place I
would add to that it's almost it's
unique and what's even more interesting
about it and delightful is that the
people or a product to this place or
extraordinary this job for many of my
peers in this business is a pain in the
neck or perhaps a little lower this job
of working with you sometimes has been a
challenge and occasionally a frustration
but has ended up generally an enormous
pleasure a pleasure because you're
extraordinary people and because you
support this extraordinary place and I
encourage you to keep doing that thank
you
[Applause]